♪ ♪
>> Greg: AS THE FEDS GET
CLOSER, THINGS GET GROSS OR PURE
THE PROBE INTO HUNTER’S
QUESTIONABLE INCOME PRACTICES
EXPAND TARGETING THE UKRAINIAN
FEELINGS, CHINA AND POTENTIAL
MONEY LAUNDERING.
FOX NEWS HAVE FEMALES IN WHICH
HUNTER ASKED A KEY BE MADE FOR
HIS NEW OFFICE MATE FOR A SHARED
SPACE WITH CHINESE ENERGY FIRMS
ADVERSARY.
THE MATE, HIS DAD, JOE, HIS
UNCLE JIM AND DR. JOE BIDEN.
IT IS ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL AND STAFF.
SO THIS STINKS LIKE A OLD DIAPER
AT A RED LOBSTER’S DUMPSTER.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER HOW LONG THE
PATHETIC MEDIA WILL PRETEND
THERE IS NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
LET’S NOTE THE CONTRAST BETWEEN
INVESTIGATION INTO SOMEONE THEY
HATE VERSUS SOMEONE THEY LOVE.
FIRST THE DOSSIER.
>> THE DOSSIER HAS BEEN
COOPERATED BY THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
THE SPEAKER THAT DOSSEY IS FAR
FROM BOGUS.
SO FAR NOTHING IN THE DOSSIER
HAS BEEN DISPROVED.
>> IT IS INACCURATE DOSSIER.
>> WHAT A BUNCH OF DOPES.
NO HUNTER.
>> WE KNOW THIS IS A CLASSIC
EXAMPLE OF THE RIGHT WING MEDIA.
>> TALKING ABOUT BIDEN, HUNTER
BIDEN AND MOST OF THOSE CHARGES
VERIFIED PEDDLING FACELESS
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON.
>> AS YOU KNOW PERFECTLY WELL,
I’M A JOURNALIST AND A REPORTER
AND I FOLLOW THE FACTS.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN ANY ISSUES
OF CORRUPTION.
>> Greg: YOU GOT TO POINT OUT
THAT YOU ARE A JOURNALIST, YOU
ARE NOT.
IT IS WORTH NOTING SINCE THE
HUNTER EVIDENCE ACTUALLY REAL, N
PAID FOR A PHONY DOSSIER AND
MEDIA TO PASS IT AROUND LIKE A
CRACK PIPE SO IT GOT RE-VERIFIED
BY OTHER.
ONE HECK SHARES IT WITH ANOTHER
AND SUDDENLY TWO SOURCES ARE
GETTING HIGH TOGETHER.
THEY DID THIS FOR FOUR YEARS AND
STILL GOT NOTHING BUT DUMBER.
MEANWHILE, HUNTER WASN’T GOING
ROGUE BUT WORKING FOR JOE TO
SECURE MILLIONS FOR HIM AFTER 50
YEARS OF SNIPPING HERA.
EXCEPT HUNTER DIDN’T FACTOR IN
NOT RETIRING.
NOW LEFT HOLDING THE BAG
WONDERING IF JILL GETS SEAMLESS?
ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT TO DO
THIS?
BUT SADLY CHINA HAS JOE OVER A
BARREL, BARREL FILLED WITH A LOT
OF DIRT.
WHAT A RELIEF FOR PRESIDENT XI
AND THOUGHT ON OUR BEHALF
INSTEAD OF CHASING POPULARITY.
NO WONDER CHINA CAN’T WAIT UNTIL
INAUGURATION.
NEITHER CAN JOE.
A LOT CAN HAPPEN IN SIX WEEKS.
WE WENT TO KAMALA HARRIS FOR
COMMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> >> Greg: SO JOE BIDEN
OFFICIALLY REACHED THE
THRESHOLD.
I THINK THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND NOT
ACTUALLY ENTERING A ROOM.
DO YOU WANT ME TO READ THIS NOW
QUESTION WORKS IN BREAKING NEWS,
CALIFORNIA PUTTING
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN OVER
THE EDGE.
I WAS TRYING TO DO THAT.
HE IS NOW 270 ELECTORAL VOTES,
AND THE NEXT MAJOR SNAP WHEN
CONGRESS HAS TO COME FROM THE
RESULTS.
SO, JESSE, I LOVE THE MEDIA
MOCKING US FOR COVERING THIS TOO
MUCH.
I THINK WE HAVE -- DO WE HAVE A
TWEET FROM CNN MEDIA GUYS OFTEN
CONSUMED BY FOX?
I DON’T KNOW IF WE HAVE IT.
IF WE DON’T COME I WILL KEEP
TALKING AND LOOKING AT YOUR
BEAUTIFUL HAIR.
I LOVE THIS PART, BOX LID THIS
HOUR WITH MORE FALLOUT FROM
HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATIONS FROM
BRIAN SALTER WHO THEN SAYS FOX
HAS A BIG PROBLEM WITH PORTION
CONTROL.
YOU KNOW, I’M GOING TO LET THAT
GO.
I’M GOING TO LET THAT GO, JESSE.
I’M NOT GOING TO THINK TERRIBLE
THOUGHTS.
[LAUGHTER]
I’M JUST GOING TO SAY THEY HAD
PORTION CONTROL PROBLEMS WITH
COLLUSION AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU TAKE IT AWAY AND I’M GOING
TO SHUT UP.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE GLUTTONOUS
WITH COLLUSION.
I TOO WILL NOT MAKE FAT JOKES.
I REFRAIN FROM THAT IN 2020 AND
I WILL STICK TO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS FUNNY THOUGH, JOE BIDEN
SHARES HIS OFFICE WITH A CHINESE
COMMUNIST FOR THREE YEARS.
SO FOR THREE YEARS HE PUTS THE
KEY IN THE DOOR, OPENS THE DOOR,
WALKS PAST THE CHINESE GUY’S
OFFICE AND THE NAMEPLATE SAYS
SOMETHING, THE GUYS NAME.
AND THEN HE WALKS TO HIS OFFICE
AND SITS DOWN.
HUNTER, WHO IS THE CHINESE GUY
NAMED DONG WE ARE SHARING AN
OFFICE WITH?
HE REPRESENTS THE EXXONMOBIL OF
CHINA, DON’T WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE WILL HOLD TEN FOR YOU.
HOW IS A REPORTER NOT ASK JOE,
HEY, JOE, DID YOU EVER GO TO
YOUR OFFICE?
WELL YOU WERE THERE, DID YOU SEE
DONG AND THAT SEEMS LIKE A
RELEVANT QUESTION WHICH SOMEONE
STILL HAS NOT ASKED, HAVE YOU
EVER MET TONY B?
LET’S GET THIS STRAIGHT HUNTER
BIDEN SON OF PRESIDENT-ELECT I
HAVE TO CALL HIM AND HE GOES
OVER TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY,
BRINGS HOME $500,000, HIDES IT
FROM THE IRS, SPENDS IT ON
ESCORTS INSTEAD, GETS PREGNANT
AND ESCORT AND A DANCER AND WHEN
SHE SAYS, CAN YOU PAY ME SOME
CHILD SUPPORT?
HE SAYS NO, NO, NO, HE FIGHTS
IT.
THIS MAKES DON JR. LOOKED LIKE
AN ANGEL.
DON JR. TURNED OVER EVERYTHING.
HE SAT FOR HOURS IN A
DEPOSITION, HANDED OVER
THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS AND
HUNTER AND HIS UNCLE JAMES ARE
STIFF ARMING CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS.
AND JOE, MEANWHILE SAYS COME I
NEVER TALK TO HUNTER ABOUT
BUSINESS.
HE WASN’T MAKING ANY MONEY AND
CHINA.
EVERYTHING WAS CLEAN IN UKRAINE
AND THIS WAS RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION PIER THAT WAS ALL
THE LIKES.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT A
LIFELONG POLITICIAN WITH A
HISTORY OF PLAGIARISM AND FAMILY
DRIFTING COULD BE SO DISHONEST?
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
JUAN, YOU GOT COVID COME A VIRUS
CHINA.
ISN’T THAT ENOUGH TO IMPEACH
JOE BIDEN?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I DON’T KNOW BUT
SOMEBODY SHOULD BE PAYING A
PRICE.
I’VE BEEN LISTENING AND I JUST
THINK TO MYSELF, YOU KNOW, WE
DON’T KNOW HOW BAD THIS IS GOING
TO GET FOR HUNTER BIDEN.
WE JUST DON’T KNOW.
BUT I DO THINK, I DO THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG TO BE
GOING AFTER BILL BARR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND SAYING HE
SHOULD HAVE EXPOSE THIS DURING
THE ELECTION.
TO MY MIND, BILL BARR WAS ACTING
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW.
SO WHAT YOU GET NOW IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO HAS HIS OWN
TAX PROBLEMS AND HIS KIDS HAVE
TAX PROBLEMS TRY TO PUT THE ONUS
AND THE FOCUS ON JOE BIDEN.
THERE IS NO INDICATION JOE BIDEN
HAS ANY ROLE IN THIS AT ALL AND
AS REGARDS TO HUNTER BIDEN,
WE’LL HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
HUNTER -- LOOK, THEY TALKED
ABOUT HIM, I DON’T THINK HE WAS
ACTUALLY THERE.
I DON’T THINK THAT WAS HIS
OFFICE, JESSE.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE I
DON’T KNOW FOR SURE.
BUT I’M JUST SAYING, IT LOOKS TO
ME LIKE TRUMP HAS NO REGARD FOR
EVEN AN ALLY, EVEN ONE OF HIS
MOST STALWART ALLIES BILL BARR
BECAUSE ALL TRUMP CARES ABOUT IS
GETTING REELECTED.
HE DIDN’T CARE ABOUT THE LAW OR
HOW THIS COUNTRY WORKS OR THE
FACT THAT WE ARE NOT A COUNTRY
OF MEN BUT A COUNTRY OF LAWS
THAT PROTECT US ALL.
>> Greg: VERY SEXIST, JUAN MEN
AND WOMEN.
DANA, THIS SHOULD BE THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL OF FULL-TIME PEER OF THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL OF FULL-TIME AND
THE MEDIA IGNORING IT.
>> Dana: WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
YOU’VE GOT TO BELIEVE IT, YOU’VE
GOT TO BELIEVE IT.
I BELIEVE THE BIDEN TRANSITION
TEAM IS KEEPING SCOOPS OF
PROBLEMS GOING INTO THEIR
TRANSITION.
ONE IS THAT ALL OF THESE OTHER
STORIES, THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
FIGHT, THE VACCINE, AND ALSO
HUNTER BIDEN IN A WAY.
AND BASKING IN THE FACT THEY
HAVE NOT HAD A GREAT ROLLOUT OF
THE NOMINEES FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN FACT, THE PROGRESSIVES ARE
QUITE UNHAPPY.
I THINK THERE WILL BE SOME
DIFFICULTY GOING FORWARD FOR
THEM THERE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO WONDER,
GEORGIA COMMUNICATIONS PEOPLE
FOR THE BIDEN TEAM, YOU THINK
EVERYDAY HOW IN THE WORLD THAT I
GO THROUGH THE WHOLE DAY NOT GET
ASKED ABOUT THE STORY?
WELL, I MUST BE A VERY LUCKY
PERSON.
>> Greg: [LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW, EMILY, YOU ARE AN
ATTORNEY.
HUNTER BIDEN IS AN ATTORNEY.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> Emily: I HOPE YOU ARE NOT
INSINUATING SOMETHING, GREG.
I WILL SAY THIS.
SO AS WE LEARN THE U.S. ATTORNEY
JOHN DURHAM IS EXPANDING HIS
TEAM, RIGHT, THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE RUSSIA COLLUSION OR A
JUMP ROPE IT IS A REMINDER TO US
ALL HOW LONG INVESTIGATIONS
TAKE, ESPECIALLY ONE THAT
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND
AREN’T JUST ABOUT TAX
AFFAIRS, BUT ARE ACTUALLY
INVOLVING CONFLICT, FOREIGN
TRANSACTIONS, AND FOREIGN
POWERS.
TWO THINGS COME TO MIND FOR ME
AND ADDITION OF THE REMINDER, A
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE FIVE YEARS TO
INVESTIGATE ONE COUNT OF TAX
EVASION.
SO THE TWO THINGS ARE ONE, THE
DUTY AND THE POWER OF THE MEDIA,
GREG AND DANA, TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT IT AND SECONDLY, THE FACT
THAT WHILE THIS INVESTIGATION,
MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS PLAY OUT
HOW CRUCIAL IT IS THAT THERE IS
A HIGHLIGHT ON EITHER CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST WITH A NOW
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN WHERE
THE PERCEIVED CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WITH HIM IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE TO KNOW
WERE RESIGNED TO THE FACT THAT
OTHER THAN SCUM OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WON’T DO IT.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
I THINK THE REAL SCANDAL IS MY
SHIRT, THE CALLER IS TOO BIG FOR